[Music]
today I'm going to say I'm different
because I'm free and the reason being is
because I just got out of prison after
23 years I should yesterday I'm free for
the first time in a long time and not
only not free for the first time in a
long time but I'm free inside I don't
know that I can get it into work but I
know that I just feel different than
other people think differently than
those people I tried not to
we're a mask I know a lot of people
tried to live their life pleasing others
or trying to conform and I did that for
a while but I'm just tired so I'm just
allowing myself to be myself more
you know creatively communicating with
people it's just any way that I can
maybe a couple things I learned a
language in 11 months it's hard to do
that that's now something I can say I
can I can do I'm out bilingual and it
took less than a year so I guess that's
how I'm different than most people
I think in today's society I feel like
I'm different because I'm a Christian
and
it's like being a Christian as there's
fat stigma to it
I just love keep on
I love the Lord and I like going about
making people happy I accept myself for
who I am
so like sometimes I'll be like oh oh I'm
bigger than most but doesn't I don't say
it as if like it's rude or negative in
any way I say because it's a part of me
and like I don't look at myself as if
I'm any less worth it than somebody
who's say skinny or more famous I look
at myself as everybody else at the
moment I'm kind of taking like an
untraditional path kind of doing the
entrepreneur Ralph J out of college
which is kind of unusual I guess I don't
feel like there's many of my buddies
that are kind of taking that route and
you know we'll see if it works out
that's kind of I guess something that
makes me different I grow weed for a
living in Denver as well and I don't
really feel like too many people do that
for a living because obviously it's not
as legal across the country I I travel a
little bit too much I've been to 57
countries so far and Counting
my upbringing what I do it's probably
quite different from other people I'm
from Japan
born and raised I'm part Japanese part
Danish none of my family lives in the
same country probably that I'm like
really good at reading people I can tell
like emotions from body language pretty
well which was - we can't do
I am unapologetically in myself
I was bought my own DNA I think that I'm
different because I can do this world I
live life on the edge I don't care what
people think I do what I want no
repercussions
I say I'm a social losing how am i
different how are you there
I think of girls in general are probably
more willing to express themselves and I
think you're a little different which I
don't mind we gave you the patient man
look I'm very patient with not to say it
hasn't been hard sometimes but all right
I love you for you I'd say I'm a little
weird I was just telling my friend here
that I'm I don't usually make a lot of
friends when I go out and I'll socialize
much I'm more of like reserved person
it's hard one to answer but I would
definitely say that a lot of people take
life for granted and I think that every
day is a blessed one especially when
you're with we care about lots of
different for most people because I like
to push myself more than others again I
like to set the bar high and challenge
myself I
push myself also in physical ways as
I've got
constraints and I just tried to push
myself through and to be a positive
person
I like crossing boundaries and
connecting with people who come from
other places over
no should I do it as a matter of
social
work I don't think I'm different at all
yeah I don't think so
I think I'm average that's it I am
unusually short for my age and unusually
white haired for my age and I have never
met a rocket I didn't love so I'm
definitely a rock hound which makes me
different from most I'm a twenty year
old still missing teeth
I have a unique sense of looking at the
world like I almost see the whole world
in a character I've got my own opinion I
guess a lot of people they how do you
say the English
they let them self lives by the stories
they hear I guess if you know what I
mean for me it's especially and that I
don't like they consume consume okay she
doesn't like like material things like
hey I got something different to say
about them okay so how do you think oh I
think this is special because the
insight that she has the heart that he
has the way that's it great people
how's he feel about things that happen
to other people and then puffy Leslie
has I think that's really special
yes that all people can do bad to do it
I don't know that many people that do
want you do it
I think that's really special
a lot of things for better or worse I
mean my mom would say my reckless nature
but I prefer tably that is an
interesting character everybody's
different that's just a fact of life
different genetics different chemical
makeup whatever point is everyone's
different I'm different because of what
I like to do I would like to do it the
way that I act where did I talk way did
I look there's no two people that are
the exact same
[Music]